and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week dressing up
as other races how is this still a thing
on Monday
MSNBC's way too early celebrated Cinco
de Mayo in a somewhat questionable
manner it is Cinco de Mayo the 5th of
May celebrating Mexican heritage and
pride is also an excuse to drink tequila
on a Monday morning at work yes that's
professional reporter and white guy Luis
Bergdorf in a sombrero drinking from a
tequila bottle because you know Mexico
but to be fair that's just one network
with bad judgment okay two networks with
bad judgment America has supposedly
evolved past its use of racial
characters in movies TV etc waters champ
at the cetera at the cetera made in
Japanese but even with racism now
officially over we don't have racism in
America anymore so just not gonna
tolerate racism some Americans just
can't seem to let go of their obsession
with dressing up in offensive outfits
Sarah high school football coaches
dressed as members of the Jamaican
bobsled team blackface and all even when
it's a shitty out-of-date reference that
no one had thought about for years yes
whether you're an elected official
Ashton Kutcher making a bold choice
in a pop ship's commercial I'm rush I'm
a Bollywood producer I'm looking for the
most delicious thing on the planet
or a fraternity attempting to celebrate
Martin Luther King Day in the worst way
possible the frat held an MLK party last
weekend where students dressed up like
gangsters then posed for pictures
holding
the desire to play demographic dress-up
run surprisingly deep even among
well-known actresses Halloween hiccup
for Julianne Hough she dressed up in
black face for a Beverly Hills Halloween
bash Kim is one of the characters from
the Netflix drama orange is the new
black
yes Julianne Hough learned two lessons
that night one wearing blackface to a
Halloween party is a terrible idea and
two if she's about to leave the house
looking like an not one of her
friends will tell her and incredibly all
this is happening at a time when there
are more costumes available in this
country than in the history of costumes
you can dress up as a fireman a nun a
slightly out of shape Captain America a
sexy rocket scientist a banana or even a
banana with a penis along with thousands
more ridiculous but non racist costumes
with all of these options it begs the
question dressing up as other races how
is this still a thing